[Music]
Sammis whether Sammy's an Albuquerque
New Mexico
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Sammy
how can I help thank you so much tonight
this is a marriage counseling call
basically we have two homes our tenants
just moved out April 30th so we're
preparing that house for sale and needs
around about three thousand dollars in
repairs carpets paint that kind of thing
we have we're in our second baby step
for taking Financial Peace University at
our church when week five we're getting
ready start week five the question is my
husband would like to put those charges
on a credit card and I'm want to use our
cash in our bank account so the fear for
him is obviously that we the unknown
when the hospital cells were paying two
mortgages which is budgeted into our
monthly income how much is on your
banker I don't do you know roughly ten
to eleven thousand okay all right so you
guys really aren't following the
financial peace baby steps anyway well
yeah there's our first month budgeting
so I don't know what you're referring to
exactly but we have you learned the baby
steps you're honest but you're in less
than $5,000 there you go and baby step
two is and every all investing stops and
all savings and non retirement investing
is used to pay off baby step two down to
that thousand dollars stuff you'd only
have a thousand dollars and then your
baby your debt would have been reduced
about ten thousand dollars okay okay so
but it turns out right now that's a good
thing
so we're early in the process there's
still a lot of things so and have you
guys been through the debt listen yeah
you have haven't you
yes I have my debt - no ball did your
husband attend the debt lesson good but
we're not on the same page and I'm
having a hard time finding out why yeah
well there's something going on because
he's he's doing his plan and you guys
aren't doing the plan that you're being
taught so that's what you got to figure
out is you under your plan or do you
want to do somebody else's plan and your
plans gotten you where you are so which
isn't working so number one underlying
this whole discussion is if it it sounds
ridiculous to me that you would be on
lesson number five and both of you have
attended the class and he even puts on
the table the possibility of using a
credit card when you have $10,000 cash
in the bank that for a $3,000 expense
this is I mean it's ludicrous in my mind
so but what that tells me is is that
he's nowhere near on this program
nowhere near
not even close you know because no one
would even dare in the in lesson 5 in
Financial Peace University to bring up
the use of a credit card if they
understood what was going on so I don't
I don't know where the disconnect is but
that's what I'd be more concerned about
then I would the actual expense but that
that's where your marriage count that's
where your marriage counseling problem
comes in that I can't help you with
because he's doing his plan and his
plans gotten you broke so I don't know
why we're doing his plan our plan is
never used a credit card again didn't
you see me cutting up those credit cards
on that video I wasn't a joke I mean
it's what we do we don't use credit
cards I don't own a credit card because
getting out of debt requires first not
borrowing more money you can't get out
of a hole while you're digging out the
bottom so the answer to your question
technically is instantly I would use
$3,000 of your savings to do this and
there's no way I would possibly consider
a credit card for any use ever except
possibly scraping the frost off my
windshield and I don't even have one to
do that with so I can't do that but
underlying all of that or the
these issues that you guys are not even
close to on the same page you're not
even close to learning how to handle
money differently and conform see here's
the thing here's what you're done
I mean both of you but him worse than
you you hired a personal trainer who
said stop eating chocolate chip cookies
and then you called the personal trainer
and said hey we want to eat chocolate
chip cookies and the personal trainer
says if you keep eating chocolate chip
cookies you're gonna keep being fat
that's what just happened in this
conversation so you got decide I mean
you can't do enough situps to eat a
whole bag of Oreos there's not enough
sit-ups in the world to cover that you
know so you've got a personal trainer
that's doing this telling you what to do
and then you have to decide are you
going to submit yourself to a different
set of behaviors practices beliefs and
attitudes in order to get a different
result so far neither one of you have
submitted yourself but he certainly has
not submitted himself to a different set
of behaviors it's not a matter of submit
yourself to Dave Ramsey that's nothing
anything to do with it I don't care I
care about you guys but I don't care if
somebody submits to me I don't need that
then I've got plenty of affirmation I
don't need that kind of crap but the
question is are you going to submit
yourself to a proven process or are you
going to continue to make your own
little plan up and do Dave ish or
Financial Peace University ish ish will
kill your button and that's what you
guys are facing Samy so the question you
need to talk about is not do we use a
credit card for these repairs the
question you need to talk about is why
are we neither one of us submitting
ourselves to this plan and if you both
look at each other and go Dave Ramsey's
crazy we're not gonna do his plan then
at least you know and then you don't
need to call me and ask me questions
because I'm gonna give you Dave Ramsey's
plan I'm not I don't have anybody else's
it's the only one I've got
so you need to decide what are you gonna
do it folks that's a good lesson for
everybody listening you know are you
going to do something
different or you gonna keep doing what
you've been doing and expecting a
different result that's the definition
of insanity if you don't like your life
change what you're doing that created
the life that you have don't keep doing
the same stupid crap and then think oh I
wonder why my life sucks if you don't
like the way your marriage is because
the way you treat each other maybe you
ought to try treating each other
different if you don't like the way your
kids are behaving maybe they need to
submit to a different plan called you
being a parent there's different things
going on here but you got to look at the
thing and say I've got new information
and I'm gonna submit myself to that set
of information beliefs practices
processes and that's gonna give me a
different result if you don't want to do
that it's a free country nobody's making
you but it is a proven plan and that's
why so many people submit themselves to
it